in some jurisdictions including Federal
courtrooms and the Supreme Court cameras
are not permitted that leaves the
responsibility of recording how Justice
plays out to courtroom sketch artists
Scott McFarland introduces us to one who
has witnessed history time and again
in a year of Blockbuster courtroom
moments there's always a reserve seat up
front for the man with the pencils and
the pad Bill Hennessy of Virginia is one
of the busiest and most prolific
courtroom artists of his time for
decades he's been sketching the drama
that plays out in front of America's
judges and juries it's my reaction to
what I'm seeing but especially over the
past year producing the first image of
the courtroom settlement between Fox
News and Dominion voting systems staying
atop a wave of January 6th prosecutions
and providing some of the only images
inside the Supreme Court he got his
start in this unique line of work while
still in graduate school someone called
and said we need an artist is there
anyone willing to go to a courtroom and
draw and I jumped at it because I need
to I need to support my families and
it's stuck as he fell in love with not
just being an artist but a journalist
seeing the newsworthy moments in each
case then sketching under fear years
deadlines you can do one of these in an
hour or two oh less if if need be yeah
less yeah I mean sometimes it's
literally uh you know a few minutes from
celebrities who've gone to court like
Chris Brown and Roger Clemens to the
historic case of bush versus Gore
sometimes people say oh you have a
photographic memory I do not that moment
just sort of Sears itself briefly and I
sketch as quickly as I can the use of a
courtroom sketch artist might seem like
an old-fashioned notion but these
artists have a bright future ahead of
them repeated efforts to require or
allow cameras in federal courts in the
U.S Supreme Court have failed Washington
defense attorney Steve McCool handles
high profile trials and knows what it's
like to be sketched by Hennessy he's
watched the proceeding and he's captured
it as an artist and he's captured a
moment in time do you ever have a bad
guy head defendant say hey could I see
how I look in your sketch yeah I
actually have I have I've had several
girl who say I want to get a copy of
that you know and I think well let's
let's see how this goes let's see if
you're still thinking that way at the
end a favorable verdict for a courtroom
Master for CBS Saturday morning Scott
McFarland Ashburn Virginia